There are certain things you should really only say to your best friend. This is probably one of them.
有些话你真的只应该对你最好的朋友说。这大概就是其中之一。
Do you ever just shut up and just listen to somebody?
你有没有试过闭嘴，只是听别人说？
Go right ahead.
请便。
That's what-- spill it out there, brother.
就是这样——说出来吧，兄弟。
I already did.
我已经说了。
Tom and Scott are in an all-night diner around midnight. Scott is disheveled and tired. He's been working all night as a bartender at a Chinese restaurant, serving lots of free drinks on the sly to Tom. And Tom, in response, seems astonishingly ungrateful. Here is the kind of sass that Tom keeps throwing Scott's way.
汤姆和斯科特在大约午夜时分来到一家通宵营业的餐厅。斯科特看起来衣衫不整，疲惫不堪。他在一家中餐馆当了一整晚的调酒师，偷偷给汤姆提供了很多免费饮料。而汤姆作为回应，显得令人吃惊地不知感恩。这就是汤姆一直对斯科特表现出的那种无礼态度。
You're the-- you're the one who needed the food and the beers and all that stuff like that to calm down after your traumatic night stealing from your employer.
你……你才是那个在因为从雇主那里偷东西而经历了充满创伤的一晚后，需要食物、啤酒和诸如此类东西来冷静下来的人。
Really?
真的吗？
Just at that moment, a man in a Hawaiian print shirt and khaki pants walks by their table. He hears the word "employer," mistakes it for the word "lawyer," and then turns to Tom.
就在这时，一个穿着夏威夷花衬衫和卡其裤的男人走过他们的桌子。他听到了“雇主”这个词，把它误听成了“律师”，于是转向汤姆。
Are you a lawyer?
你是律师吗？
No.
不是。
No. Do you want to be?
不，你想当律师吗？
Who brought up a lawyer to start with? You just came-- walked in--
到底是谁先提到律师的？你只是——走进来——
You did.
是你。
No, I didn't. Not at all.
不，我没有。根本没有。
He didn't say lawyer.
他没说律师。
You thought that you heard something and then you let your mind take over and then it got you in-- it put you in--
你以为你听到了什么，然后你就让你的大脑占了主导，然后它让你陷入了——它把你带进了——
Well, I am a lawyer, so that's probably why I might have thought that. But you know what? I'm trained in the art of listening, and I could've sworn you said you wanted to be a lawyer.
好吧，我是一名律师，所以这大概就是我为什么会那么想的原因。但你知道吗？我受过倾听艺术的训练，我可以发誓你说过你想当律师。
Well, I definitely wouldn't hire you because you heard completely wrong.
好吧，我绝对不会雇佣你，因为你听得完全错了。
Really?
真的吗？
Yeah.
是的。
There's some conversations that you overhear and it's hard not to want to keep listening or to butt in, even though everybody knows that it is not the right thing to do. One Sunday morning a while back, I was sitting in one of the booths in this very diner, the Golden Apple, in Chicago on Lincoln Avenue, and I looked around the restaurant. The table next to me, a family was taking their teenage daughter out to an awkward last breakfast before she shipped out with the military. There were dressed-up people who'd come in from the church across the street, and young couples who'd stumbled in with the paper and were working on the crossword together. And I thought, if only somebody could interview every person at every table in this restaurant. That would be amazing. You'd get such a wide variety of different kinds of stories from different kinds of people. So we decided to try it.
有些对话是你无意中听到的，很难不想继续听下去或插嘴，尽管每个人都知道那是不对的。很久以前的一个周日早上，我正坐在芝加哥林肯大道的这家餐厅，即金苹果餐厅的隔间里，我环顾四周。我旁边的桌子上，一家人正带着他们十几岁的女儿吃着尴尬的最后一顿早餐，之后她就要去参军了。有从街对面教堂过来的盛装打扮的人，还有拿着报纸跌跌撞撞走进来、一起做填字游戏的年轻情侣。我想，如果有人能采访这家餐厅每张桌子上的每个人，那该多棒啊。你会从各种各样的人那里得到极其广泛的故事。所以我们决定试一试。
One Friday night, a big group of us took shifts starting at 5:00 AM and going to 5:00 AM the next morning. During quiet hours, it was just one of us on duty, recording and interviewing people. During the busiest hours, which means late night, three or four of us worked the tables. We first broadcast today's program all the way back in 2000, and we'll be running it again today. From WBEZ Chicago, today's show, "24 Hours at the Golden Apple." It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay tuned.
一个周五晚上，我们的一大群人轮班，从早上5点开始，一直到第二天早上5点。在安静的时段，我们只有一个人值班，负责录音和采访。在最繁忙的时段，也就是深夜，我们有三四个人在负责这些桌子。我们最早是在2000年播出的今天的节目，今天我们将再次重播。来自WBEZ芝加哥电台，今天的节目是《金苹果餐厅的24小时》。这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
It's 5 o'clock in the morning. My name is Pete. I work from 10:00 PM to 5:00 AM, and now we're going to have the taxi drivers and the cops, you know, come for a cup of coffee until 6 o'clock, the morning crowd is going to be in.
现在是凌晨5点。我叫皮特。我从晚上10点工作到早上5点，现在出租车司机和警察要来喝杯咖啡，直到6点，早晨的客流就会到来。
Pete's one of the three owners of this restaurant, along with Nick and Tom. All three are Greek, and one of them is always there 24 hours a day. The restaurant sits at one of those intersections where three streets come together, not two, so every one of the corners in the intersection is wedge-shaped, which means that the restaurant itself is wedge-shaped, with booths along the windows on two sides of the wedge.
皮特是这家餐厅的三位老板之一，另外两位是尼克和汤姆。三个人都是希腊人，其中一个人总是24小时待在那里。这家餐厅坐落在一个三条街道交汇的十字路口，而不是两条，所以十字路口的每一个拐角都是楔形的，这意味着餐厅本身也是楔形的，楔形两边的窗户旁设有隔间。
There's a counter with stools and a larger room with tables in the back. There are those oversized, laminated menus that go on for pages-- pages-- with pictures of the food. By the door is one of those revolving dessert cases, an octagon made of glass. Three shelves of cream pies and melon slices and cakes. Lately, it's been nothing but trouble. Here's Nick, another one of the owners.
前面有一个带凳子的柜台，后面有一个带桌子的大房间。菜单是那种超大的覆膜菜单，长达好几页，上面还有食物的照片。门边有一个旋转的甜点柜，是一个玻璃制成的八角形柜子。三层架子上摆满了奶油派、甜瓜片和蛋糕。最近，它一直问题不断。这是尼克，另一位老板。
It's supposed to be turning. It's not turning because the motor broke. Jimmy's supposed to come out like three days ago. He's still coming. Now, if you can figure this one out, the-- the pie case is not turning. And believe it or not, it's not selling as good. That's-- that's a truth.
它应该是旋转的。它不转是因为电机坏了。吉米本该三天前就来。他到现在还在路上。现在，如果你能弄清楚这一点，这——这派柜不转了。信不信由你，它的销量也变差了。这是——这是事实。
Dessert sales are down, he says, by half, ever since it broke. People just like desserts more when they're in motion.
他说，自从它坏了以后，甜点销量下降了一半。人们在甜点转动时更喜欢它们。
It catches the eye. You know, when it's turning, it catches the eye and it sells.
它很吸引眼球。你知道，当它转动时，它会吸引人们的注意，然后就会卖出去。
Over the course of 24 hours, the staff of the Golden Apple changes, the regulars who come in change, and the atmosphere changes, from quiet in the early morning to crazy hectic late at night when the bars in the neighborhood let out. Nancy Updike took the first shift of our 24-hour surveillance, mic in hand, from 5:00 AM till 10:00 AM.
在24小时的过程中，金苹果餐厅的工作人员在变，进来的常客在变，氛围也在变，从清晨的安静到深夜附近酒吧散场时的疯狂喧闹。南希·厄普代克负责了我们24小时监测的第一班，从早上5点到上午10点，手里拿着麦克风。
This is Eddie. He comes to the Golden Apple a few times a week in the mornings and plays the harmonica in the middle of the restaurant for a few minutes. He's in a pale blue shirt and hopping lightly from foot to foot.
这是埃迪。他每周早上来几次金苹果餐厅，在餐厅中间吹几分钟口琴。他穿着浅蓝色衬衫，轻快地从一只脚跳到另一只脚。
I might fall down.
我可能会摔倒。
[HARMONICA]
[口琴声]
Eddie heads to the back of the restaurant to play there. No one is complaining. No one is rolling their eyes. In fact, a few people are smiling and saying hi. Eddie is not an outsider here. He's a regular.
埃迪走向餐厅后部在那里演奏。没有人抱怨。没有人翻白眼。事实上，几个人在微笑并打招呼。埃迪在这里不是外人。他是常客。
Early morning at the Golden Apple is like that, a profoundly democratic place. Early morning welcomes the night shift workers, the unemployed, the retired, the confused, the disappointed, the slightly off. The people who work for themselves and the people who don't work at all anymore, but crave a little morning routine.
清晨的金苹果餐厅就是这样，一个极其民主的地方。清晨欢迎夜班工人、失业者、退休人员、困惑的人、失望的人、稍微有点怪异的人。那些为自己工作的人，以及那些根本不再工作但渴望一点早晨作息的人。
Every morning, I'm here between 4:30 and 5:00. I love the Golden Apple. They're wonderful people. They got good food. And that's it.
每天早上，我都在4点半到5点之间来这里。我喜欢金苹果。他们是很棒的人。他们的食物很好。就是这样。
This is how Joe Molica ends every sentence.
这就是乔·莫利卡结束每句话的方式。
And that's it.
就是这样。
Or sometimes--
或者有时——
And that's all I could tell you, honey.
这就是我能告诉你的全部了，亲爱的。
Joe's not used to talking about himself. His story comes out bit by bit. Our entire conversation takes place in a different era. He's completely unselfconscious about calling me honey. He bangs on his coffee cup with his spoon to get the waitresses attention for a refill. Please don't try this at home, but he gets away with it.
乔不习惯谈论自己。他的故事是一点一点出来的。我们整个对话发生在一个不同的时代。他完全不觉得叫我“亲爱的”有什么不妥。他用勺子敲击咖啡杯，引起服务员的注意，要求续杯。请不要在家尝试，但他这样做却没事。
I do construction, remodeling, rehab. And that's what I do. I retired. I'm 78 years old. And I gave the business to my two sons and that's it.
我做建筑、改造、翻新。这就是我所做的。我退休了。我今年78岁了。我把生意交给了我的两个儿子，就是这样。
How did you start that business?
你是怎么开始那门生意的？
Through my dad. My dad done the same thing. When I was, I don't know, maybe 10, 11 years old, I started working for him. He was paying me a dime an hour and that was it. Clean up, sweep up the floors that he's working on. What else you want to know, honey?
通过我父亲。我父亲做同样的事。当我，我不知道，大约10、11岁时，我开始为他工作。他每小时付我一角钱，就是这样。清理，打扫他工作的楼层。你还想知道什么，亲爱的？
At 5:30 in the morning, almost everyone is sitting alone, by choice, it seems. Joe's friend Bob is sitting in his own booth behind Joe. No one's talking much, but it's a comfortable silence. When you're up this early, it's hard not to feel some sense of community with everyone else who's awake. But you don't necessarily want to talk to them.
凌晨5点半，几乎每个人都独自坐着，似乎是自愿的。乔的朋友鲍勃坐在乔身后的隔间里。没人怎么说话，但那是一种舒适的寂静。当你起这么早时，很难不感到一种与其他醒着的人的社区感。但你不一定想和他们交谈。
As it gets lighter and lighter outside, more people trickle in. A guy with thick, dark blond hair and a face that looks like it could use another six hours' sleep sits down at the counter. His name is Scott Johnson, and he says he usually comes in around 3:30 AM, but today's different.
随着外面越来越亮，更多的人陆续进来。一个有着浓密深金色头发、脸上写着“还需要再睡六小时”的男人坐在柜台边。他叫斯科特·约翰逊，他说他通常在凌晨3:30左右来，但今天不同。
It's about 20 after 7:00.
现在大概是7点20分。
How did you start coming to the Golden Apple?
你是怎么开始来金苹果餐厅的？
I own a bar right down the street. It's called Wits. And I own another one on Clark and Oakdale called Jake's.
我在街那头有一家酒吧。叫Wits。我在克拉克和奥克代尔还有一家叫Jake's的。
How did you get into the bar business?
你是怎么进入酒吧行业的？
Oh, boy. Well, about eight years ago, I turned 30, quit my career, got a divorce, and bought a bar in the same month.
噢，天哪。好吧，大约八年前，我30岁，辞去了工作，离了婚，在同一个月里买了一家酒吧。
Oh, my god.
噢，天哪。
Took the Etch-a-Sketch and shook it. Just turned it upside down and shook it real hard and changed my life forever.
拿起了画板把它摇匀了。只是把它倒过来，用力摇了摇，彻底改变了我的生活。
It's completely light outside now. Commuter traffic is picking up. The Golden Apple isn't crowded, but all the front booths are taken, and most of the counter. Nick keeps getting deliveries-- orange juice, potatoes-- and his butcher comes by, John Zervas. John is a big man in that way that's the norm in Chicago. Not fat, just big.
外面现在完全亮了。通勤交通开始繁忙。金苹果餐厅并不拥挤，但前面的隔间都坐满了，柜台也大部分坐满了。尼克不断收到货物——橙汁、土豆——他的肉贩约翰·泽瓦斯也来了。约翰是一个在芝加哥很常见的体格魁梧的男人。不是胖，只是大。
John has been eating at the Golden Apple and supplying its meats for 10 years. When he was eight years old, he became famous for being the youngest butcher in Illinois.
约翰在金苹果吃东西并供应肉类已经10年了。他8岁时就因成为伊利诺伊州最年轻的屠夫而出名。
Back in 1979, I was interviewed by Fahey Flynn. I don't know if you remember. Back in 1979, Fahey Flynn was a well-known newsman right here at Channel 7 news before he died in '81. I was the youngest butcher in Illinois in 1979.
早在1979年，我就接受过法希·弗林的采访。我不确定你是否记得。1979年，法希·弗林在1981年去世前是7频道新闻的一位著名新闻工作者。我在1979年是伊利诺伊州最年轻的屠夫。
And yeah, I've met Governor Thompson down Randolph Street. My father was in a retail business still out on Randolph Street. And that's how I started learning how to cut. So I've been doing this for-- I'm 33 now and since I was, like, eight years old.
是的，我在伦道夫街见过汤普森州长。我父亲当时还在伦道夫街做零售生意。这就是我开始学习切割的方法。所以我在做这个已经——我现在33岁了，从我大约8岁起。
You were a butcher when you were eight?
你8岁时就是屠夫了？
Well, yeah, I'd been involved, you know, cleaning tables. And about 12 years old, I started cutting meat on a band saw.
嗯，是的，我参与过，你知道，清理桌子。大约12岁时，我开始在带锯上切割肉类。
Wow. Do you remember the first piece of meat you cut?
哇。你还记得你切的第一块肉吗？
Pork chops. Piece of pork loin and I sliced it. I remember very well, like it was yesterday. Real slow on a band saw. Pork chops. Pork loins like 18 pounds. First thing I did is cut it down the middle and start from the middle. The trick is, at the end, not to cut your hands when it comes really small. You got to use a special kind of thing that's underneath the band saw, not to put your hand in it because the band saw doesn't have any friends. I mean, if it's going to grab your hand, it's going to cut it.
猪排。一块猪里脊肉，我把它切开了。我记得很清楚，就像昨天一样。在带锯上真的很慢。猪排。像18磅重的猪里脊肉。我做的第一件事是把它从中间切开，然后从中间开始。诀窍是，在最后，当它变得很小时不要切到你的手。你必须使用带锯下面的一种特殊的东西，不要把手放进去，因为带锯可不认人。我是说，如果它要抓住你的手，它就会割断它。
The front of the Golden Apple is the smoking section. Sitting there is a grayish woman with a fleshy face and wavy hair in one of the small, two-person booths. Her name is Alice Deluca.
金苹果餐厅的前面是吸烟区。坐在那里的是一个脸色灰暗、面部肉乎乎、留着波浪发型的女人，坐在一个小型的双人隔间里。她叫爱丽丝·德卢卡。
I work at a purification center. It's sauna, running, vitamins and minerals. It's a program to rid your body of toxins and radiation.
我在一家净化中心工作。那里有桑拿、跑步、维生素和矿物质。这是一个帮你身体摆脱毒素和辐射的项目。
Wow. Have you done the program yourself?
哇。你自己做过这个项目吗？
Yes, I have.
是的，做过。
Now, to the naked eye, it looks like you're smoking and drinking coffee.
现在，肉眼看来，你似乎在抽烟和喝咖啡。
Yes.
是的。
And about to have some sausage. So how does that square with the whole toxins thing?
而且马上要吃一些香肠。那么这和整个毒素问题怎么协调呢？
Well, I'm trying to wake up.
好吧，我正在努力醒过来。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
You need some toxins to wake up?
你需要一些毒素来醒过来？
I guess so.
我想是的。
The restaurant never gets crowded this morning. Turnover is slow. People linger over their coffee or their conversation. It's a weekday, so there's no impatient brunch crowd waiting for tables to open up. And if you don't have an office you need to get to, why rush? Donna, the waitress, is finishing up the night shift and getting ready to go home. She's been on since 11:00 PM, but you would never know it to look at her. She's six feet tall and looks like Catherine Deneuve. She's one of the most beautiful people I've ever seen in person.
今天早上餐厅从来没有变得拥挤。翻台率很慢。人们在咖啡或谈话中流连忘返。这是一个工作日，所以没有急躁的早午餐人群在等待桌位。如果你不需要赶去办公室，为什么要着急呢？唐娜，这位服务员，即将结束夜班，准备回家。她从晚上11点就开始上班了，但你看她绝对看不出来。她有六英尺高，长得像凯瑟琳·德纳芙。她是我亲眼见过的最漂亮的人之一。
How long have you been working here?
你在这里工作多久了？
Oh, 26 years.
噢，26年了。
Wow. How old were you when you started?
哇。你开始工作时多大？
Well, you think I'm going to tell you that? [LAUGHS] Are you kidding? My kids don't even know how old I am.
嗯，你以为我会告诉你吗？[笑声]你在开玩笑吗？我的孩子们甚至都不知道我多大。
Donna says she's actually not a night person, but she's worked the night shift the entire time, all 26 years. She came to Chicago from Oklahoma City in her early 20s with three kids.
唐娜说她其实不是一个夜猫子，但她这26年来一直上夜班。她在20岁出头时带着三个孩子从俄克拉荷马城来到芝加哥。
I was divorced when I came here, and I had married so young, had my children young. No education. And I had a little baby. That's why I started working nights. But this is a great job for that. I mean, working nights, that way you're with them during the day. You don't sleep much, but-- when they're asleep and you're working. And I'm still working the night shift. I don't know why, but I still am.
我来这里时已经离婚了，我结婚太早，生孩子也早。没受过教育。我还有一个小宝宝。这就是为什么我开始上夜班。但这是一个很好的工作。我是说，上夜班，这样你白天就能和他们在一起。你睡得不多，但是——当他们睡着而你在工作时。我依然在上夜班。我不知道为什么，但我还在上。
Every Christmas Eve, Donna brings in a big tray of homemade cookies for the homeless guys and the old men and the taxi drivers-- anyone who shows up that night. Every once in a while, on her afternoon off, she'll go see a play starring one of the actors who come in every night after their own shifts waiting tables. Her customers give her tapes of the bands they're in, bring in their artwork for her see, tell her about their successes and failures. These are people she's known for years.
每个平安夜，唐娜都会为流浪汉、老人们和出租车司机——那天晚上出现的任何人——带一大盘自制饼干。偶尔，在她休假的下午，她会去看一场由每晚下班后在餐厅等位的演员主演的戏剧。她的顾客给她他们所在乐队的磁带，带他们的艺术作品给她看，告诉她他们的成功和失败。这些人是她认识多年的朋友。
It's like home here to me. And when I think about going on a day job, I just can't. It's almost like it'd be another div-- you know, a separation because it's like home when you've been here this long.
这里对我来说就像家一样。当我想到去做一份日班工作时，我就是做不到。这几乎就像是另一次分——你知道，是一种分离，因为当你在这里待了这么久，这里就像家一样。
Donna runs her shift at the Golden Apple with a lot of compassion and generosity. But like any good waitress, she's also ruthlessly practical. She can be direct when she needs to. Early morning is no time to stand on ceremony.
唐娜带着极大的同情心和慷慨管理她在金苹果的轮班。但像任何好的服务员一样，她也非常务实。在需要时，她可以直接了当。清晨不是讲究礼节的时候。
Honey, I got to get finished with the rest of my work.
亲爱的，我得去完成剩下的工作了。
All right. Can I-- are you doing anything to set up or clean up?
好的。我可以——你在做任何设置或清理工作吗？
I got to check and see what I've got to do.
我得检查一下看看我必须做什么。
Can I just follow you around and you tell me what you're doing? I'll just like--
我能跟在你后面，你告诉我你在做什么吗？我可以就像——
Well, I don't even know if I have anything more to do. I just didn't want to talk anymore.
嗯，我甚至不知道我还有没有什么要做。我只是不想再说话了。
Oh, OK.
噢，好的。
I didn't want to be rude, but--
我不是想粗鲁，但是——
No, no, no. You're [INAUDIBLE].
不，不，不。你是[听不清]。
I just told her I'm tired of talking. [LAUGHS]
我只是告诉她我厌倦了说话。[笑声]
In the middle of the day, a muted light streams through the windows through a pale haze of cigarette smoke. At certain hours, it feels like everybody is smoking at the Golden Apple. Three industrial smoke-eaters, a non-stop. At lunch, some customers come in, eat quickly, and head back to work after just a half hour, but they're in the minority. Probably 3/4 of the customers are regulars. Many of them stay for hours. Nick, the owner, says some come two or three times a day.
在中午，柔和的光线透过香烟的淡雾照射进窗户。在某些时段，感觉金苹果餐厅里每个人都在吸烟。三台工业吸烟器，不停地工作。午餐时，一些顾客进来，迅速吃完，半小时后就回去工作了，但他们是少数。可能3/4的顾客都是常客。他们中许多人一待就是几小时。老板尼克说，有些人一天来两三次。
I mean, they go home and sleep, of course, but this is their base. We got Charlie right now, and there are some that comes twice, three times a day. Floyd, which is right next to him. Mitch. Mitch with his son on the counter. He's a counter man. Mr. Harland there with Steven. They come twice a day. Russ comes about three, four times a day. Al, two, three times a day.
我是说，他们当然会回家睡觉，但这里是他们的大本营。我们现在有查理，有些人一天来两次、三次。弗洛伊德，就在他旁边。米奇。米奇带着儿子在柜台。他是柜台常客。哈兰先生在那儿和史蒂文一起。他们一天来两次。拉斯一天来三四次。阿尔，一天两三次。
At the counter, a man who looks a little bit like the actor Harry Dean Stanton, scruffy and lean, is here for the second time in 24 hours. He gives me what he says is his nickname, Robert. He says he usually just comes for coffee. Can't afford much else.
在柜台边，一个长得有点像演员哈里·迪恩·斯坦顿、邋遢而瘦削的男人，24小时内第二次来到这里。他给了我他所谓的昵称，罗伯特。他说他通常只是来喝咖啡。负担不起其他东西。
So why do you come here?
那你为什么来这里？
Just something to do. Coffee. I come over here because I'm single, no wife, no girlfriend. No kids either.
只是找点事做。咖啡。我来这里是因为我是单身，没有老婆，没有女朋友。也没有孩子。
Robert is one of three different men who tell me that they come here in the afternoon to drink coffee and talk to the waitresses. All three actually seem a little shy and intimidated by the waitresses. Robert is so bashful, he has a hard time saying much of anything to them.
罗伯特是三个告诉我他们下午来这里喝咖啡并和女服务员聊天的人之一。这三个人看起来对女服务员都有点害羞和胆怯。罗伯特非常腼腆，很难对她们说出什么话来。
I've never said more than hello, you know, or goodbye. That's all I ever said. I don't know what to do with a pretty girl, what to say. I don't know what to say.
我从来没说过除了你好以外的话，你知道，或者再见。那就是我说的全部。我不知道拿美女怎么办，说什么。我不知道该说什么。
At a table in the back, Manuel Hernandez is here for the second time today. He's a retired carpenter. Came to Chicago from Mexico in 1965 as one of the workers who built the Sears Tower downtown, one of the tallest buildings in the world. He quit, he says, when they got to the 105th floor.
在后面的桌子上，曼努埃尔·埃尔南德斯今天第二次来到这里。他是一位退休木匠。1965年从墨西哥来到芝加哥，是建造市中心西尔斯大厦的工人之一，那是世界上最高的建筑之一。他说，当他们到达第105层时，他就辞职了。
It was too windy up there. After two guys, they-- they fall down, and then I quit because I don't want to be the next.
上面风太大了。在两个人——他们掉下去之后，我就辞职了，因为我不想成为下一个。
As the afternoon passes, he calls over one of the waitresses, Sherry, and asks her for help reading a document that he got in the mail from an insurance company. He's worried it's some kind of scam. She reads it, tells him no. They've sent him a check. It's real. Sherry says this kind of thing happens all the time. Some of these guys, who else do they have to turn to?
随着下午的流逝，他叫来了服务员之一谢里，让她帮忙阅读他从保险公司收到的邮件。他担心那是什么诈骗。她看了看，告诉他没有。他们寄给他一张支票。是真的。谢里说这种事情经常发生。有些人，他们还能向谁求助呢？
Out on the sidewalk when the weather's good, the restaurant sets up tables. At one, Allison Musgrave and her two kids are eating. Ian is four, Madeline is two. Both are wearing their bicycle helmets at the table and eating the Mickey Mouse pancakes. Three pancakes arranged in violation of US copyright law. Two ears and a head, maraschino cherries, canned pineapple, and whipped cream as the eyes and mouth. Cover it with maple syrup and you have a sugar concoction so powerful that four-year-old Ian literally cannot sit in his chair.
在人行道上，天气好时，餐厅会摆放桌子。在其中一张桌子上，艾莉森·马斯格雷夫和她的两个孩子正在吃东西。伊恩四岁，马德琳两岁。两人都戴着自行车头盔在桌边吃米老鼠煎饼。三个煎饼的排列方式违反了美国版权法。两个耳朵加一个头，加上马拉斯奇诺樱桃、罐头菠萝，还有作为眼睛和嘴巴的生奶油。盖上枫糖浆，你就得到了一种如此强效的糖分混合物，四岁的伊恩简直无法坐在椅子上。
Ian, Ian. Around here, please. Thank you.
伊恩，伊恩。在这儿，拜托。谢谢。
[IAN MUTTERING BABY TALK]
[伊恩发出婴儿般的嘟囔声]
I don't live far from here and I do not think there is a four year old in a 10-block radius who does not know the Mickey Mouse pancakes.
我住得离这儿不远，我不认为方圆10个街区内有一个不知道米老鼠煎饼的四岁孩子。
Turn around now, Ian. Turn around, please.
转过来，伊恩。转过来，拜托。
The restaurant has toys for kids in a corner inside. One couple named Mike and Liz tell us that they come here so often with their four and seven year old and feel so at home here that they've instructed their kids that if they're ever lost, they're supposed to find a policeman and tell them not to bring them home. Bring them to the Golden Apple.
餐厅里有一个角落有给孩子们的玩具。一对叫迈克和莉兹的夫妇告诉我们，他们经常带着四岁和七岁的孩子来这里，并在这里感到非常自在，以至于他们告诉孩子们，如果他们走丢了，就去找警察，告诉他们不要把他们送回家。把他们送到金苹果餐厅。
As evening falls, it takes a while for the dinner crowd to show up in any kind of force. It's a slow day, everybody says. It is Friday, and couples start to arrive. Some on dates, some just friends. Some in that vague territory in between. The topics of conversation in the room start to make an orbital shift toward couples sorts of topics. One of our producers, Susan Burton, notices one couple in particular.
夜幕降临，晚餐人群花了一段时间才以某种规模出现。每个人都说这是沉闷的一天。今天是周五，情侣们开始到达。有些是约会，有些只是朋友。有些处于两者之间模糊的领域。房间里的谈话话题开始向情侣类话题偏移。我们的一位制片人苏珊·伯顿注意到了一对特别的情侣。
A man and a woman in their 30s sit down in a booth by a window. The man's long hair is tied back with a bandanna.
一名30多岁的男子和一名女子坐在靠窗的隔间里。男子的长发用头巾扎在脑后。
I'm Daniel Romero. Silvia and I just got through playing a few sets of tennis in Grant Park, and stopped at Healing Earth for a little incense and some good karma. And we decided to stop and grab a bite.
我是丹尼尔·罗梅罗。西尔维娅和我刚在格兰特公园打了两场网球，在“治愈地球”店停下来买了一些香和一点好运。我们决定停下来吃点东西。
You know, Sylvia and I have this kind of weird history. She actually dumped me not too long ago. And-- that's right.
你知道，西尔维娅和我有一段奇怪的历史。她其实不久前甩了我。而且——那是真的。
That's a long time ago, Romero.
那是很久以前的事了，罗梅罗。
Well, not that long ago. So she's-- she's now happily in a relationship, and I was telling her as we were driving here about how lonely I am.
嗯，没那么久以前。所以她——她现在正幸福地恋爱中，我在开车来这里的路上一直在告诉她我有多孤独。
Actually, it's been three years since Daniel and Sylvia broke up. They met when they worked together at the same nonprofit organization.
事实上，丹尼尔和西尔维娅分手已经三年了。他们是在同一家非营利组织工作时认识的。
Well, you're ready to settle down now.
嗯，你现在准备安定下来了。
I am.
是的。
Well, I'm proud of you. I'm proud of you. I actually-- when you first told me that, I actually wasn't sure.
嗯，我为你感到骄傲。我为你感到骄傲。其实——当你第一次告诉我时，我其实并不确定。
Right. But you will not be coming to the wedding. You already told me that.
对。但你不会来参加婚礼。你已经告诉过我了。
I did-- I did-- I did tell you that. I won't be participating there. You'll have my best wishes.
我确实——我确实——我确实告诉过你。我不会参与其中。你会得到我最好的祝愿。
Why? We're friends. I still love you and care about you. Why can't you be there?
为什么？我们是朋友。我依然爱你，关心你。为什么你不能去？
Well-- [LAUGHS] well, why can't-- it would just be weird. I mean, you and I have a pretty significant history together. But I would-- I would still be happy for you and you'd have my best wishes, and I'll still buy you a toaster.
嗯——[笑声]嗯，为什么不能——那只是会很奇怪。我是说，你和我有一段相当重要的历史。但我会——我依然会为你感到高兴，你会得到我最好的祝愿，我依然会给你买个烤面包机。
A toaster? OK. See, I think that that's unusual. I think-- I would be very happy for you. Would I have some feelings there? Yeah, maybe there would be a little twinge, thinking why-- why wasn't it me?
烤面包机？好的。你看，我认为那不寻常。我想——我会为你感到非常高兴。我会有一些感觉吗？是的，也许会有一点刺痛，想着为什么——为什么不是我？
That's actually a Sex in the City topic a lot.
那其实是《欲望都市》里的一个热门话题。
Right.
对。
Absolutely.
当然。
In case you've missed it, Sex and the City is a TV show on HBO. Each episode circles around some central question, like, can you be friends with your ex? If Daniel and Sylvia and I were suddenly cast in our own episode of the show, this would be the moment where I would light a cigarette and flip open my PowerBook and ponder what I'd seen.
如果你错过了，《欲望都市》是HBO的一档电视节目。每一集都围绕着某个核心问题，比如，你能和前任做朋友吗？如果丹尼尔、西尔维娅和我突然出演我们自己的一集节目，这就是我会点上一根烟，翻开PowerBook，思考我所见所闻的时刻。
Daniel and Sylvia began by talking about Sylvia's new boyfriend, but wound up discussing each other. And I started to wonder, when you talk about your ex's new relationships, are you really just talking about the two of you?
丹尼尔和西尔维娅以谈论西尔维娅的新男友开始，但最终讨论起了彼此。我开始好奇，当你谈论你前任的新恋情时，你真的只是在谈论你们俩吗？
I didn't tell you this. You asked me how my love life was a little bit earlier. I did meet somebody about a week ago. Her name is Amy and she works at-- where does she work at? She works at Supercuts. And she was with her-- her boyfriend, actually.
我没告诉你这个。你刚才早些时候问过我的爱情生活怎么样。我大约一周前确实遇到了某个人。她叫艾米，她在——她在哪里工作？她在Supercuts工作。而且她其实正和她的——她的男朋友在一起。
And she was hitting on you?
她在向你调情吗？
And she was hitting on me. She said to me, I want to go out with you. And I said, fine, let's go out. She says, well, you have to wait a month because I'm still going out with this idiot over here. I mean, and she's talking about, you know-- so nothing happened though. But nothing happened.
而且她在向我调情。她对我说，我想和你出去。我说，行，那我们出去吧。她说，好吧，你得等一个月，因为我还在和这边这个白痴约会。我是说，她在谈论，你知道——但什么也没发生。什么也没发生。
But you would go out with a woman who would degrade her boyfriend that way? Who would treat the guy that she's supposedly dating that way?
但你会和一个那样贬低她男朋友的女人出去吗？和一个那样对待她所谓的约会对象的人出去？
Yeah, but I'm not going to marry-- I'm not going to marry this girl, you know? I mean-- you know, I mean, I wasn't interested in a lifetime commitment at that moment. I mean, I was much more looking for the immediate gratification.
是的，但我不会娶——我不会娶这个女孩，你知道吗？我是说——你知道，我是说，在那一刻我没兴趣做出终身承诺。我是说，我更多是在寻找即时的满足感。
That's what you're always looking for.
那正是你一直在寻找的。
That's not entirely true. That's not entirely true.
那并不完全正确。那并不完全正确。
Each time Daniel brings up someone he's interested in, Sylvia gets exasperated with him for refusing to make a commitment. It happens when he mentions the woman he saw in a lounge chair by a pool in Las Vegas, and the girl he's taken on a dozen dates, but is pretty sure he wants to break up with. It turns out that this is a conversation they've had before, at the end of their own relationship.
每当丹尼尔提到他感兴趣的人时，西尔维娅都会因为他拒绝做出承诺而对他感到恼火。当他提到他在拉斯维加斯游泳池边的躺椅上看到的那个女人，以及他约会了十几回但很确定想和她分手的那个女孩时，就会发生这种情况。事实证明，这是他们之前在他们自己的关系结束时谈过的话题。
I was ready for the next step and he was ready to back out. Any time I pressed forward, he went backwards a couple steps.
我已经准备好迈出下一步，而他准备退缩。每当我向前推进，他就向后退几步。
You're right. You and I were in a place where you were frustrated because I couldn't move forward. I was frustrated because you were pressing so hard. And right--
你说得对。你和我当时处在一个你因为我无法前进而感到沮丧的地方。我因为你逼得太紧而感到沮丧。而对——
And then you met the next girl and moved in with her after three weeks. I think it's a hard topic for us both.
然后你遇到了下一个女孩，三周后就和她同居了。我认为这对我们俩来说都是个沉重的话题。
Absolutely, absolutely. Yeah, it's just-- you know, the thought of-- you know, it's like--
当然，当然。是的，这只是——你知道，想到——你知道，这就像——
He trails off, staring out the window.
他没有说完，盯着窗外。
I don't know, it's kind of hard to-- it's kind of hard to--
我不知道，这有点难——这有点难——
It is kind of hard to talk when two babes go by.
当两个美女经过时，确实有点难说话。
Yeah.
是的。
Outside on the sidewalk, two girls with blond hair and short skirts approach. They catch Daniel's eye. He mumbles. As the girls stride by the window, he turns his head and follows them from one end of the glass to the other. The gesture seems to happen in slow motion.
在外面的人行道上，两个金发短裙女孩走了过来。她们吸引了丹尼尔的目光。他喃喃自语。当女孩们大步经过窗前时，他转过头，从玻璃的一端跟到另一端。这个姿势似乎是在慢动作中发生的。
He does that all the time.
他总是那样做。
Yeah, but I-- I'm not-- but--
是的，但我——我不是——但——
I know, I know. I'm not saying that.
我知道，我知道。我不是那个意思。
Yeah, I understand.
是的，我明白。
I'm just saying that when we were together and you did that, that really hurts.
我只是说当我们在一起时你那样做，那真的很伤人。
Even if-- even though it's just looking?
即使——即使那只是看看？
It says you're not interested in what's going on right here, and that's exactly--
那说明你对眼前发生的事情不感兴趣，而这正是——
No, see, that's--
不，看，那是——
--you did by doing that. You couldn't even formulate the sentence because your eyeballs were glued to that window.
——你通过那样做表达的。你甚至无法组织好句子，因为你的眼珠子粘在了那扇窗户上。
Look, this-- this is another-- this has-- this has been another topic on Sex and the City.
听着，这是另一个——这已经是——这已经是《欲望都市》里的另一个话题了。
Just for the record, what actually happened in that episode, the woman got so mad at her boyfriend that she punched him in the face. And then she realized she couldn't change him.
顺便说一下，那一集里实际发生的事情是，那个女人对她男朋友感到非常生气，以至于她扇了他一耳光。然后她意识到她无法改变他。
Over by the restaurant's front windows, which look out on St. Alphonsus Catholic church, a huge building, sits Kay Frank, known to her friends as Katie Keane, 75 years old, dressed in a nice outfit and matching scarf. She's here because one of her longtime neighbors, another Golden Apple customer, is laid out dead in the funeral home right across the street. She'll eat and pay her respects. She tells me that she's lived her whole life within walking distance of this very spot.
在餐厅的前窗边，可以看到街对面的圣阿尔方斯天主教堂（一座巨大的建筑），凯·弗兰克坐在那里，朋友们叫她凯蒂·基恩，75岁，穿着漂亮的衣服和配套的围巾。她在这里是因为她的一位长期邻居，另一位金苹果餐厅的常客，就躺在街对面的殡仪馆里。她吃完饭后会去表达哀悼。她告诉我，她一辈子都住在离这个地方步行可达的范围内。
Yeah. I was born and raised on Lakewood 75 years ago. Went to St. Alphonsus School, so this is my neighborhood for a long time.
是的。我75年前出生并在莱克伍德长大。去了圣阿尔方斯学校，所以这里长期以来就是我的邻里。
Wow.
哇。
And it gives me a lot of pleasure to walk the neighborhood and say, Margaret Kuntz lived in that house, Lucille Sutchell lived in that house. I can still see all the things in my mind as I did in the '30s and '40s.
漫步在街区并说，玛格丽特·昆茨住在那座房子里，露西尔·萨切尔住在那座房子里，这给了我很多乐趣。我依然能在脑海中看到所有的事情，就像我在30年代和40年代所做的那样。
Back then, for instance, a pharmacy was on this spot. Kay and her friends would come here after 11 o'clock mass.
那时，例如，这个地方是一家药店。凯和她的朋友们会在11点弥撒后来到这里。
I'm talking about first year, second year high school, when you didn't go to the kiddie mass anymore at 9 o'clock in the morning. This was like a hangout here after mass. And this whole section here, they had a wonderful soda fountain. It was right here where this would be. See what I'm saying?
我说的是高一、高二的时候，那时候你不再去早上9点的儿童弥撒了。这里就像是弥撒后的聚会场所。整个这一区域，他们有一个很棒的汽水吧。就在这儿。看到我说什么了吗？
She points at a section of booths. For years, this neighborhood was all about which parish you belonged to. St. Alphonsus for the Germans, St. Andrews for the Irish and Italian, St. Josaphat for the Polish. Till finally, in the 1960s, that ended. Kay's five sisters and her parents all moved away from the neighborhood.
她指着一排隔间。多年来，这个社区的一切都取决于你属于哪个教区。德国人属于圣阿尔方斯，爱尔兰人和意大利人属于圣安德鲁斯，波兰人属于圣约瑟法特。直到最后，在20世纪60年代，那结束了。凯的五个姐妹和她的父母都搬离了这个社区。
I'm the only one that stayed in the neighborhood because we couldn't afford to move out of here. We bought our house in the mid-'60s, '64. And everybody thought the neighborhood was going to change. So of course, they're moving to the suburbs or farther north or farther west.
我是唯一一个留在社区的人，因为我们负担不起搬出去的费用。我们在60年代中期，64年买了我们的房子。每个人都以为社区会改变。所以当然，他们搬到了郊区或者更远的地方，北方或者西方。
Change? You mean people thought it wasn't going to be white anymore?
改变？你是说人们认为这里不再是白人的区域了？
They thought-- yes. They thought it was going to go down. That's why people were scared and moved out. So we couldn't afford to move, so we bought a house there for $27,000. I've had offers of $500,000, $550,000 for my house.
他们认为——是的。他们认为这里会走下坡路。这就是为什么人们感到害怕并搬走了。所以我们负担不起搬家，所以我们花27,000美元在那儿买了一栋房子。有人出价50万、55万美元买我的房子。
Meanwhile, one of her sisters who moved away to avoid the blight of this area, who moved to an area too expensive for Kay or her husband to afford, just sold her house for only $200,000. Gentrification, which spread through this neighborhood in the last 15 years, hasn't made it out to where her sisters live. But around here, on Southport and on Clark and all over, there are little boutiques and several Starbucks, and expensive restaurants with fake European names.
同时，她的一个为了逃避这个地区的衰落而搬走的姐妹，搬到了一个凯或她丈夫负担不起的地区，刚刚以仅20万美元的价格卖掉了她的房子。士绅化在过去15年里席卷了这个社区，但并没有延伸到她姐妹居住的地方。但在这一带，在绍斯波特和克拉克以及各地，到处都是精品店和几家星巴克，还有名字虚假的昂贵餐厅。
The neighborhood has changed a lot, you know? A whole lot. Some for the better, some for the worse. Close by, we have our gay people, which we never had as a kid. They were around, maybe, but we didn't know who they were. Today, you know who they are.
社区变了很多，你知道吗？改变很大。有些变好了，有些变坏了。在附近，我们有我们的同性恋群体，这是我小时候从来没有过的。他们也许就在周围，但我们不知道他们是谁。今天，你知道他们是谁了。
My husband, coming from the old school-- we have the nicest neighbors we've ever had, two gay men. They can't do enough for you. They cut your grass for you. They water-- now that I'm older. And when they moved in, my husband, coming from way back, oh, my god, you know, he didn't want really too much to do with them.
我丈夫，来自老派——我们有我们住过最好的邻居，两个男同性恋。他们为你做什么都不为过。他们帮你割草。他们给——现在我老了。当他们搬进来时，我丈夫，来自过去，噢，天哪，你知道，他真的不想和他们有太多瓜葛。
Within a year, I'd say, we saw that they were nice people, very clean. And when we had our 50th wedding anniversary party, had some [NON-ENGLISH] here, it was our neighbors that went to the hall without any-- they wouldn't take a penny. They decorated that place like you wouldn't believe. Now, how many neighbors would do that for you, you know?
我想一年之内，我们看到他们是很好的人，非常干净。当我们举行50周年结婚纪念派对时，在这里有过一些[外语]，是我们的邻居去了礼堂，没有任何——他们一分钱也不拿。他们把那个地方装饰得让你不敢相信。现在，有多少邻居会为你那样做，你知道吗？
So gay or not gay, they're really nice people. So I think that the gays can be credited for being such a nice people. They swayed a lot of the old-time people into different thinking. There's still a lot of racial stuff. Maybe if you had a black neighbor here, or one of the people would rent to a black person, I think they'd be frowned upon a little bit. But if you rent to a gay person today, it's OK.
所以无论是同性恋还是不是，他们真的是好人。所以我认为同性恋者可以因为是这么好的人而受到赞扬。他们改变了很多老派人的想法。这里依然有很多种族主义的东西。也许如果你有一个黑人邻居在这里，或者有人愿意租给一个黑人，我认为他们会受到一点点的鄙视。但如果你今天租给一个同性恋者，那是可以的。
A lot of things that we think should be this way and that way as you grow up, it's really not that way, shouldn't be that way. So I don't feel that we should really judge them, you know? Let the Lord judge them.
很多我们认为随着成长应该这样或那样的事情，其实并不是那样，不应该是那样。所以我不认为我们应该真的评判他们，你知道吗？让上帝去评判他们吧。
Coming up, drunks, partyers, people on the make, and lots of other people to try not to judge. I mean, we have not even gotten to the cops. In a minute, from Chicago Public Radio-- warm up that coffee for you?-- when our program continues.
接下来，醉汉、聚会者、想入非非的人，还有许多其他人，尽量不去评判。我是说，我们甚至还没聊到警察。一会儿回来，来自芝加哥公共广播电台——给你暖暖咖啡？——我们的节目继续。
It's This American Life, I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program, "24 Hours at the Golden Apple." If you're just tuning in, we tried to interview every person at every table of a 24-hour restaurant here in Chicago, starting at 5:00 AM in the morning on Friday, July 14, going to 5:00 AM the next morning. Not everybody said yes. Not everybody could fit into a one-hour radio show. And the day is just heating up.
这是《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目是《金苹果餐厅的24小时》。如果你刚刚收听，我们试着采访了芝加哥一家24小时餐厅里每一张桌子的每一个人，从7月14日周五早上5点开始，一直到第二天早上5点。不是每个人都答应了。不是每个人都能放进一小时的广播节目里。而这一天刚刚开始热起来。
Let's jump ahead to midnight. One of the owners, Pete, is explaining something sort of surprising about a restaurant like this to our reporter Wendy Dorr.
让我们跳到午夜。老板之一皮特正在向我们的记者温迪·多尔解释关于这样一家餐厅的一些令人惊讶的事情。
We never close. We have no keys. We got no keys. If you see the doors, we have no locks. Always open. We'll never, never lock the doors.
我们从不关门。我们没有钥匙。我们没钥匙。如果你看这些门，我们没有锁。永远开放。我们永远，永远不会锁门。
Just at that moment, a young woman burst through the door. Laughing, she swivels around and drunkenly tries to lock it to keep her two friends out. It takes a second before she realizes there are no locks. The three stumble to a table.
就在这时，一个年轻女人冲进门。笑着，她转身，醉醺醺地试着锁上门把她的两个朋友挡在外面。过了一秒她才意识到根本没有锁。三个人跌跌撞撞地走向一张桌子。
This is Kim. I'm at the Golden Apple. I know I am. And I'm with Oscar and Beth. Oscar. Oscar, who I have no idea where he is. Beth and I are riding in a cab, and he like hops in. I've never even met this guy. I need to order food. I'm a journalism major, by the way. Yeah. So I understand what you're doing right now.
这是金。我在金苹果。我知道我在哪儿。我和奥斯卡还有贝丝在一起。奥斯卡。奥斯卡，我完全不知道他在哪儿。贝丝和我正在打车，他就像跳了进来。我甚至都不认识这家伙。我需要点吃的。顺便说一下，我是新闻专业学生。对。所以我理解你现在在做什么。
I work with Kim. And Kim lives-- I don't live downtown. I live in the suburbs. And Kim was like, OK, we went to--
我和金一起工作。金住——我不住在市中心。我住在郊区。金就像，好了，我们去了——
I live downtown though.
但我住在市中心。
Right.
对。
I do.
我住的。
That's right. She lives in Sheffield. It doesn't matter. Anyway, so we go to this premiere party of the Star Wars exhibit at the Field Museum.
就是这样。她住在谢菲尔德。没关系。总之，我们要去菲尔德博物馆的星球大战展的首映派对。
Yes. It was so awesome, by the way.
是的。顺便说一下，太棒了。
Kim, this is my story.
金，这是我的故事。
Look at my stars. Look, do you see it?
看我的星星。看，你看到了吗？
Yeah, she sees it.
是的，她看到了。
Star Wars.
星球大战。
I'm the most sober one here, as you can probably tell. So anyway--
我是这里最清醒的一个，就像你大概能看出来的那样。总之——
I'm sorry. I'm drunk.
抱歉。我喝醉了。
That's fine. I-- I meet Oscar. We just meet him, like, standing at the bar, and he offers-- he buys us a couple shots. So we're like, you know, fine. We started drinking with him. We start talking to him.
没关系。我——我遇到了奥斯卡。我们只是遇到他，就像，站在酒吧边，他提议——他请我们喝了几杯酒。所以我们就像，你知道，好吧。我们开始和他一起喝酒。我们开始和他谈话。
Oh, so I'm sitting there talking to Kim. All of a sudden, I feel two hands on my back. Two hands I do not recognize. Two hands I do not want on my body. And I look and who do I see?
噢，我坐在那儿和金聊天。突然，我感觉到背上有两只手。两只我不认识的手。两只我不想要它们在我身体上的手。我一看，我看到了谁？
[INAUDIBLE]
[听不清]
It is Oscar, and I don't even know your last name, do I?
是奥斯卡，我甚至不知道你的姓，对吧？
Which we're not going to say on the radio.
我们不在电台说这个。
I'll be honest. I will-- I will be honest with you. He paid for a lot of tonight. Like, he paid for my drinks. OK, great. You know what? Don't touch me, but you can buy my drinks for me. If you're going to hop into the cab and pay for it, then fine, I'll let you get into the cab with me. That's fine. And he's probably going to buy our food here tonight. So that's fine with me.
老实说。我会——我会对你诚实。他付了今晚的很多费用。我是说，他付了我的酒钱。好吧，太棒了。你知道吗？别碰我，但你可以为我付酒钱。如果你要跳进车里并付钱，那行，我会让你和我一起上车。那没问题。他今晚大概会买我们吃的食物。所以那对我来说没问题。
The brutal truth.
残酷的真相。
What?
什么？
The brutal truth. It's the brutal truth.
残酷的真相。这是残酷的真相。
I'm just-- I'm just honest. I'm not going to go home with you.
我只是——我只是诚实。我不会和你回家的。
My name's Oscar. I bought them-- I bought them a drink or two.
我叫奥斯卡。我给她们买了——我给她们买了一两杯酒。
Or a bottle of $300 champagne, OK?
或者一瓶300美元的香槟，好吗？
I'm successful, what can I say?
我很成功，我能说什么呢？
And gloat.
而且自鸣得意。
We didn't even have to pay when we walked in.
我们走进去时甚至不用付钱。
I'll be completely honest with you. My goal is to share a bed tonight. Yeah. I'm going to end up with both of them.
我会对你完全诚实。我的目标是今晚共用一张床。是的。我最终会和她们俩在一起。
See, it doesn't matter which one. It's just to share a bed. He just wants to get some play, basically. Is that what you're saying, Oscar?
看，不管哪一个都无所谓。只是要共用一张床。他基本上只是想玩玩。奥斯卡，你是这个意思吗？
And I'll bet you, if you follow us home, one of them two will be in bed with me tonight. Would I be sitting here talking to you in front of a microphone eating breakfast with them if I was not going to go home with them tonight? Either I'm a complete moron or-- or I know something that you don't.
我敢打赌，如果你跟着我们回家，她们俩其中一个今晚会和我上床。如果我没打算今晚带她们回家，我还会坐在这里对着麦克风和她们一起吃早餐吗？要么我是个彻头彻尾的白痴，要么——或者我知道一些你不知道的事情。
You're just a sleaze ball.
你真是个混蛋。
I really hate him, Beth.
贝丝，我真的讨厌他。
Oscar, you're a good guy. I understand you have a lot of hormones and that's fine with me. You're just not going to be able to act on them tonight-- with me. I don't know about you.
奥斯卡，你是个好人。我明白你有荷尔蒙，这对我没关系。你只是今晚没法付诸行动——和我。我不了解你。
Not me either. Unless it's paying by food. Where the hell's the waitress?
我也不行。除非是用食物买单。服务员到底在哪儿？
I don't know.
不知道。
I just want to know where the waitress is.
我只是想知道服务员在哪儿。
By 1 o'clock, the diner is at capacity and it feels like one big party. A woman sits in a booth in the back with a friend. She's in her early 40s, grew up in the neighborhood.
到1点，餐厅已经满座，感觉就像一场大派对。一个40出头的女人和朋友坐在隔间里。她在这一带长大。
My name is Nancy. Where am I and what time is it? Well, I don't think I'm really here. I think that there's-- I'm doing like a two-dimensional kind of thing. So there's part of me that's here, and then there's part of me that's somewhere else, the future me. So what time is it? Earthly time, it's 1:15 AM, and there is no time where my future self is.
我叫南希。我在哪儿，几点了？好吧，我不觉得我真的在这儿。我觉得这儿有——我在做一种二维的事情。所以有一部分我在这是这儿，然后有一部分我在别的地方，未来的我。所以几点了？地球时间是凌晨1:15，而我的未来自我所在的地方没有时间。
You know how you-- when you go to sleep and you dream, how you can bend and shape the events that take place in that dream? Well that-- what if that were your reality and what if this were the dream, you know? You can actually paint your future and you can make everything that's ever happened, is happening, and will happen has already happened. It's shapeshifting time and events so that you know why your soul is here. And that's the purpose, to know why you're here. To know why you came back.
你知道当你睡觉做梦时，你是怎么可以弯曲和塑造那个梦中发生的事件的吗？好吧那——如果那是你的现实，而这如果是梦呢，你知道吗？你其实可以描绘你的未来，你可以让过去发生过的一切，正在发生的，以及将要发生的，都已经是发生过的了。这是改变时间和事件，这样你就知道你的灵魂为什么在这儿。这就是目的，知道你为什么在这儿。知道你为什么回来。
I know one past life, I was a cowboy and I was shot by accident. And I've met two of my four buddies that I was with together here at-- we-- we agreed to come back on some kind of subliminal basis. So yeah, I was a cowboy in one lifetime, probably right before the turn of the century. And my other lifetime, I really don't know, but I know I was crushed. And I don't know by what, but probably a large building. I haven't identified the time yet. I'm still working on that. Can I have-- can I have a short stack, please? That's all. Thank you.
我知道一个前世，我是一个牛仔，我是意外被枪杀的。我在这里遇到了当时和我在一起的四个哥们中的两个——我们——我们商定以某种潜意识的方式回来。所以是的，我在其中一世是个牛仔，大概是在世纪之交前。我的另一世，我真的不知道，但我知道我被压扁了。我不知道被什么，但大概是一栋大楼。我还没确认时间。我还在努力。我可以要——我可以要一小份煎饼吗，拜托？就是这样。谢谢。
Not far away, in another booth, sit Danielle, who's 17, and Allison, 18. They're best friends. A month ago, because of problems at home, Danielle moved in with Allison's family. They both live in the basement there now. They've been driving in from the suburbs to the Golden Apple to hang out, meet friends-- guys mostly.
不远处，在另一个隔间里，坐着17岁的丹妮尔和18岁的艾莉森。她们是好朋友。一个月前，因为家里的问题，丹妮尔搬到了艾莉森家里。她们现在都住在地下室里。她们一直从郊区开车来到金苹果餐厅闲逛，见朋友——主要是男生。
We're sitting here waiting for this guy Jeff, who's hopefully going to come.
我们坐在这儿等杰夫这个家伙，希望他能来。
We've just been coming here for the last three nights at about midnight, 1 o'clock.
过去三个晚上我们一直都在午夜、1点左右来这里。
Because we're bored.
因为我们无聊。
Just sitting here waiting for random people to show up.
只是坐在这儿等随机的人出现。
She kind of has a crush on this guy, and so we kind of come here in hopes to find him. It hasn't worked yet.
她有点迷恋这家伙，所以我们为了找到他来这里。还没成功呢。
You paged him and told him to come here.
你呼叫了他，告诉他来这儿。
Yeah, I paged him and told him to come here.
是的，我呼叫了他，告诉他来这儿。
Paged him, no answer. Paged him again, no answer. Paged him again. No answer.
呼叫他，没回复。又呼叫他，没回复。又呼叫他。没回复。
So basically, we have no life, so we come down here and wait for people.
所以基本上，我们没生活，所以我们来这里等人。
All right, phone call time. Do you have the number?
好了，打电话时间。你有号码吗？
Yeah, I have the number. All right, give me money. All right. I am calling this guy Jeff and I'm going to make him come here because my best friend wants him to. All right. And it's still ringing. Hi, Jeff. We are at the Golden Apple and I am wondering if you're at all coming because Allison kind of wants to see you, and I'm not going to stick around here all night because I have to sleep. So hopefully you'll be here by like 2:00. If not, call Allison tomorrow. All right, bye. And he'll be here. He'll be here. Err. Six messages on his machine at home.
有，我有号码。好了，给我钱。好了。我给杰夫这家伙打电话，我要让他来这儿，因为我最好的朋友想要他来。好了。还在响。嗨，杰夫。我们在金苹果餐厅，我想知道你到底会不会来，因为艾莉森有点想见你，我不会在这里待一整晚，因为我得睡觉。所以希望你能在2点左右到这儿。如果不行，明天给艾莉森打电话。好了，再见。他会来的。他会来的。嘿。他家答录机上有六条留言。
I just called Jeff and told him that he's not here and he should be. I still think he will come, I just don't know when.
我刚给杰夫打电话告诉他他没在这儿，他应该在这儿的。我依然认为他会来，我只是不知道什么时候。
See, the thing that makes this a big deal is the fact that I think he actually might like me back, which doesn't happen ever. So that's why I, like, want to see him again.
你看，这事为什么重要，是因为我觉得他其实可能也喜欢我，这种情况从来没发生过。所以我才想再次见到他。
You want to know the really weird thing about us? Is she, like, hates herself. She never likes anyone ever. And whenever anything goes right, she freaks out.
你想知道关于我们真的很奇怪的事情吗？是她，像，恨她自己。她从来不喜欢任何人。每当事情进展顺利时，她就会抓狂。
Seriously, like, you say that there's so many people that like me, but how many times has it actually ever worked out? It's not hard for you because you're just like this massive guy magnet. You know, and you act sometimes like you don't see it. You see it. You got to see it. Because we go somewhere, and it's like, whoosh, and everyone's there by you. And not even just guys. Like, you're just-- like, people like you, you know? It takes no effort.
说真的，像你说的那样，喜欢我的人很多，但真正进展顺利的有几次？对你来说不难，因为你就像是一个巨大的“帅哥磁铁”。你知道，你有时表现得好像你没看到。你看到了。你一定看到了。因为我们去哪儿，就就像，“呼”的一下，每个人都在你身边。甚至不仅仅是男人。人们就是——人们就是喜欢你，你知道吗？毫不费力。
But it's not-- no, you're wrong, though.
但那不是——不，你错了。
No, I'm not.
不，我没。
Because it's not like I just get them like that. It's-- err! OK, I'll give you sometimes it just-- I don't know why, but sometimes, it happens like that. And it's the fact that I talk and I'm not, like, boring and I don't just sit there. No, I'm not saying you're boring. I'm just saying that that's what I'm not.
因为事情并不是说我就能那样得到他们。这——嘿！好吧，我承认有时它只是——我不知道为什么，但有时，情况就是那样。这是因为我说话，我不是，像，无聊，我不仅仅坐在那儿。不，我不是说你无聊。我只是说那才是我不是的样子。
People, like I said before, are robots and they're going to want to follow the life of the party. That's how people are. If you put an idea in their head-- like, if one person says you're a good kisser, you are deemed a good kisser forever and ever and ever.
人们，就像我之前说的，是机器人，他们会想要追随派对的灵魂人物。人们就是这样。如果你在他们脑海里灌输一个想法——就像，如果一个人说你是个好吻手，你就会永远被视为一个好吻手。
That's the point. Like, you have this thing where you just like radiate positive vibes, you know? And you're always, like, upbeat, you know? When I've been really outgoing, or trying to be, I'm like almost imitating you to see if it works. It doesn't work for me.
重点就在这儿。就像，你有一种特质，你就是散发着积极的正能量，你知道吗？你总是，像，很乐观，你知道吗？当我表现得真的很外向，或者试图那样做时，我简直是在模仿你看看行不行。这对我不管用。
And you know, we're best friends, especially now that you live with me. It's like you're just always there, so the issue is always there. When you didn't live with me, you know, sometimes I'm not even thinking about it. I don't care. But now you're there all the time and, you know, we've been, like, going out more and it's always there.
你知道，我们是最好的朋友，尤其是现在你和我住在一起。就像你总是那儿，所以问题一直都在。当你没和我住在一起时，你知道，有时我根本没想过。我不在乎。但现在你一直在那儿，你知道，我们一直，像，出去更多，而问题一直都在。
It is 1:25 almost. OK, I am calling my friend Marion in hopes that he is up. OK. Marion? Are you sleeping? You are? We're just at the restaurant and waiting for people, and no one's coming. So we were wondering, do you want us to come pick you up? Say yes. To come back here. Just say yes. No, say yes. So don't go to sleep. Oh, come on. You know you love me. Thank you. I will be there to pick you up in like two minutes. Bye.
差不多1:25了。好了，我正在给我的朋友马里昂打电话，希望他还醒着。好了。马里昂？你在睡觉吗？你在？我们就在餐厅等朋友，一个人也没来。所以我们想，你想让我们去接你吗？说愿意。回来这里。只要说愿意。不，说愿意。所以别去睡觉。噢，拜托。你知道你爱我。谢谢。两分钟后我就去接你。再见。
So we're here. Hi, Marion.
所以我们在这儿。嗨，马里昂。
Hi, I can't go anywhere.
嗨，我哪儿也去不了。
[LAUGHS] You can't go anywhere? Get in the car.
[笑声]你哪儿也去不了？上车。
I cannot.
我不能。
Marion.
马里昂。
I cannot. My mom has convinced me to stay.
我不能。我妈说服我留下来。
Marion, go tell her that you have to come back to the restaurant.
马里昂，去告诉她你必须回餐厅。
I can't-- I have to wake up at 8:00 tomorrow morning.
我不能——我明天早上8点得起床。
Marion, I'm going to go beat you up.
马里昂，我要去揍你。
Danielle, however, does not do such a good job convincing him with her fists. Actually, she doesn't try. He won't come. So she climbs back into the car to head back to meet Allison, who's waiting back at the Golden Apple.
然而，丹妮尔用拳头说服他的效果并不好。其实，她没试。他不来。所以她爬回车里，赶回去见正在金苹果餐厅等待的艾莉森。
OK, me and Allison. I think that she feels like we're growing apart because I-- I've kind of been mean lately. Not like-- not like too mean. But like, she's my best friend. She will always be my best friend. It's just like now that we live together, we have constant each other. And it's just like we realize the things that we could overlook before are actual issues now.
好了，我和艾莉森。我想她感觉我们正在疏远，因为我——我最近有点刻薄。不是像——不是像太刻薄。但像，她是我的好朋友。她永远会是我最好的朋友。只是现在我们住在一起，我们总是待在一起。我只是觉得，我们之前可以忽略的事情现在成了真正的问题。
Like, we're complete opposites. She doesn't like people. I love people. She likes staying home and reading. I can't stand staying home and I can't stand reading. And I mean, I don't-- I don't like thinking. It's like thinking is something you do in school, and then when you need to.
就像，我们是彻底的对立面。她不喜欢人。我爱人。她喜欢呆在家里看书。我受不了呆在家里，我也受不了看书。我是说，我不想——我不想思考。就像思考是你在学校做的事情，然后是当你需要时才做的。
And she is not like that, and that's very cool. I mean, it shows that, you know, she's not a robot or whatever, you know? But she's 17. She's only 17. And she acts like she's 23. She's, I guess, above, you know, the normal teenager. She thinks of things. She-- she cares, you know?
而她不是那样，那很酷。我是说，这表明，你知道，她不是一个机器人或者其他什么，你知道吗？但她才17岁。她才17岁。她表现得好像她23岁。我想，她超越了，你知道，正常的青少年。她思考事情。她——她在乎，你知道吗？
And that's what people in college do and that's what, you know, older people do. But me and most of all my friends, we're not ready. We're not-- we don't want to do that, you know? We want to-- we want to just sit back and have fun.
那是大学里的人做的事，那是，你知道，年长的人做的事。但我，还有我大多数的朋友，我们还没准备好。我们不想那样做，你知道吗？我们想——我们只是想坐下来玩得开心。
I mean, she just needs to find the right people to hang out with. And for right now, it's not my thing. This is my thing. I like this scene, where it's just like, we're going to sit back. We're going to have fun. We're going to laugh. We're just going to let everything go, you know? Just like, all right. The Golden Apple scene. Yeah.
我是说，她只是需要找到合适的人一起玩。而目前，那不是我的事。这是我的事。我喜欢这个场景，我们只是，我们要坐下来。我们要玩得开心。我们要笑。我们要让一切都过去，你知道吗？就像，好了。金苹果场景。是的。
When she's back in the restaurant, after all this thinking about how she and Allison are so different, she heads over to her best friend. They started a band together called Mixed Emotions, just the two of them. Allison plays guitar. They both sing. And they do one of their songs together now for the microphone.
当她回到餐厅时，在思考了她和艾莉森是多么不同之后，她走向她最好的朋友。她们一起组建了一个叫“混合情绪”的乐队，只有她们两个人。艾莉森弹吉他。她们俩都唱歌。她们现在一起为麦克风表演了一首她们的歌。
Ready?
准备好了吗？
(SINGING) So much for faith, so much for loving you. So much for everything you told me you would do. So much for love. You won't believe in me. So much for all the times you say you'll never leave.
（歌唱）信仰到此为止，爱你也到此为止。你告诉我会做的所有事也到此为止。爱到此为止。你不会相信我。你说你永远不会离开的所有时光也到此为止。
I needed you and thought you'd be there, but now I see the change in you. And now you just don't seem to care.
我需要你，以为你会在这儿，但现在我看到了你的改变。现在你似乎根本不在乎。
So much for faith. So much for loving you.
信仰到此为止。爱你也到此为止。
They skooch in tight to each other near the mic as they sing. Allison's sitting, Danielle's standing, leaning in close. And then, the thing that they had been waiting for all night finally happens. Sort of.
她们唱歌时紧贴在麦克风旁边。艾莉森坐着，丹妮尔站着，贴得很近。然后，她们整晚都在等待的事情终于发生了。算是吧。
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[交叉说话]
This is Jeff. That's Juan.
这是杰夫。那是胡安。
He's got a face for radio.
他长了张适合广播的脸。
That's Billy. This-- OK, yeah.
那是比利。这——好吧，是的。
Oh, Billy's here.
噢，比利在这儿。
It is 2:15 and they have finally arrived. Yeah. Like--
现在是2:15，她们终于到了。是的。像——
When we'd given up all hope, poof, they're here. It's the greatest thing.
当我们放弃所有希望时，噗，他们来了。这是最棒的事。
I told you. I knew it. I never gave up faith.
我告诉过你。我知道。我从来没放弃信仰。
They all sit down together. The guys who they've been waiting for, who they called six times, Jeff, he never arrived. But there is another Jeff with this group, and Allison transfers her crush to Jeff number two. At some point, Danielle drags her outside the diner to confer. They stand on the sidewalk, just on the other side of the plate glass window Jeff number two and everybody else. Allison reviews the facts of the case.
他们都坐在一起。她们一直在等的那些家伙，她们打了六次电话，杰夫，他从来没到。但这群人里有另一个杰夫，艾莉森把她的迷恋对象转移到了二号杰夫身上。在某个时刻，丹妮尔拉她离开餐厅去商量。她们站在人行道上，就在二号杰夫和其他所有人的落地玻璃窗对面。艾莉森回顾了案情事实。
Well, it's just like, OK, he's-- you know, he's into some of the supernatural stuff too--
好吧，就像，好了，他——你知道，他也对某些超自然的事情感兴趣——
Uh-huh.
嗯哼。
--and we have a lot of things in common. Like, we're both big Tim Burton fans and-- so-- I don't know. I actually had something to talk to him about for hours now. And-- but then again, it's like, what's the point of liking him if he doesn't like me? So--
——我们有很多共同点。像，我们都是蒂姆·伯顿的超级粉丝，所以——我不知道。我其实现在有事情可以和他聊上几个小时。但是话又说回来，像，如果他不喜欢我，迷恋他有什么意义？所以——
Do I ask him?
我要问他吗？
No.
不。
I'm just going to go and be like, OK, here, look. I'm trying to hook her up and--
我只是要去表现得，好了，看。我试着帮她搭线——
Don't.
别。
OK. I was wondering. I'm trying to set Allison-- I'll be slick. It'll be fun.
好了。我只是好奇。我想帮艾莉森安排——我会很滑头。会很有趣的。
For you, yeah.
对你来说是吧。
I'll give him a flower. Come on, it'll be fun. If he says no, we just won't come out here ever again. Please.
我会给他一朵花。拜托，会很有趣的。如果他说不，我们就再也不来这里了。拜托。
No.
不。
Whatever else it might do for Allison if she were hooked up with somebody, it might just reduce the general level of tension between her and Danielle. And Danielle does not take no for an answer. She gives the flower to Jeff number two, saying it's from Allison. He smiles a big number two smile, then he and Allison sit alone at a table and talk for a while until Danielle comes over.
无论艾莉森如果和一个搭上关系的人在一起会怎么样，这可能会减少她和丹妮尔之间的一般紧张程度。丹妮尔不接受“不”这个答案。她把花给了二号杰夫，说是艾莉森给的。他露出一个二号杰夫的大笑脸，然后他和艾莉森单独坐在桌边聊了一会儿，直到丹妮尔过来。
Are we leaving now?
我们要走了吗？
Yes, we paid and we left a tip, and I put the rest of the change in this little box here. And now we're leaving.
是的，我们付了钱留了小费，我把剩下的零钱放进了那个小盒子里。现在我们要走了。
It can be our research foundation.
它可以成为我们的研究基金会。
It was fun. We got here at like 11:30 and it is now 3:15. And it is time to leave, so we'll be back tomorrow. Bye.
很有趣。我们大概11:30到的，现在已经3:15了。是时候走了，所以明天我们会回来的。再见。
Bye.
再见。
Good night.
晚安。
By 4:00 AM Saturday morning, things have finally started to die down. Once again, like when we arrived the day before, it's mostly cab drivers and cops.
到周六凌晨4点，情况终于开始平息下来。再一次，像我们前一天到达时那样，大部分是出租车司机和警察。
What was that show Florence was on? With Mel's Diner? What the hell's the name of that show? Alice? No.
弗洛伦斯上的那个节目是什么？叫《梅尔餐厅》的？那节目的名字叫什么鬼？《爱丽丝》？不。
These two police officers are sitting in a booth in front. Even on a break, they are required to wear 18-pound bulletproof vests. They call over their waitress, Donna, to help settle this question.
这两个警官坐在前面的隔间里。即使在休息时，他们也被要求穿上18磅重的防弹背心。他们叫来服务员唐娜帮忙解决这个问题。
Let me ask Donna. Maybe she knows. Hey, Donna.
让我问问唐娜。也许她知道。嘿，唐娜。
Do you want another [INAUDIBLE]?
你还要[听不清]吗？
Oh, no thank you. What's the TV show that-- where they were in the diner with--
噢，不，谢谢。那个电视剧叫什么——他们在那个餐厅里——
Mel's Diner with--
《梅尔餐厅》和——
Flo. Flo. Flo was the redhead.
弗洛。弗洛。弗洛是那个红发女。
Yeah, Flo was the one waitress.
对，弗洛是一个服务员。
It was Alice and Flo and Vera.
那是《爱丽丝》、弗洛和薇拉。
Yeah, it was-- and it was Mel's Diner.
对，那是——那是《梅尔餐厅》。
Vera was the dark hair. Flo was the Western. And then Alice was the one from New York.
薇拉是深发那个。弗洛是西部那个。然后爱丽丝是纽约来的那个。
But it was called Flo's, I think.
但我认为那叫《弗洛的》。
No, it wasn't called Flo's.
不，那不叫《弗洛的》。
No.
不。
No?
不是吗？
It was-- I think it was Alice.
那是——我想是《爱丽丝》。
I'm stumped. Now I won't be able to sleep today till I find out what the name of that show was. I'm Officer Norman Knudsen, and this is my partner.
我被难住了。今天不查出那个节目的名字我睡不着觉。我是诺曼·克努森警官，这是我的搭档。
Officer Clark Eichman.
克拉克·艾克曼警官。
We work beat 1922 tonight in the 19th district. We're on a personal. We're allowed as many personals as we want for coffee breaks, use the washroom, whatever. And so it's almost 5 o'clock in the morning, AM. OK, 0500 hours.
我们今晚在第19区负责1922辖区。我们在进行私人休息。我们被允许进行任意次数的私人休息，用于咖啡休息、上厕所等等。所以现在快凌晨5点，AM。好了，0500小时。
It's often-- this district normally is slow. But on the weekends, it's like any other district. Gun calls, fights--
通常，这个区正常时很慢。但在周末，它和其他区一样。枪击报警、打架——
Narcotics.
毒品。
--narcotics. It's real busy for two days a week and real slow for five.
——毒品。它一周忙两天，五天很闲。
With all the bars on Lincoln and Clark, and even further north on Lincoln, you can go from one jab to another. One fight after fight after fight after fight. We had a bar fight over at Irish Eyes.
林肯大街和克拉克大街上有这么多酒吧，甚至林肯大街更北边，你可以从一个麻烦跑到另一个麻烦。一场接一场又一场的打架。我们在“爱尔兰之眼”酒吧打过一架。
One of the guys is going to need plastic surgery.
其中一个人需要整形手术。
Yeah.
是的。
Because he got hit with a beer stein in the face.
因为他脸部被啤酒杯砸中了。
You know, Sox fan versus Cubs fan. OK, the Cubs fan got hit in the face with a stein. And then we had another brawl over at Cubby Bear, where we made three arrests. And we just got done with all the paperwork and it's been, what, two and a half hours on the paperwork.
你知道，白袜队粉丝对小熊队粉丝。好了，小熊队粉丝脸部被杯子砸了。然后我们在“小熊熊”酒吧又有了一次斗殴，我们逮捕了三个人。我们刚做完所有文书工作，这花了，什么，两个半小时的文书工作。
Yeah. Yeah.
对。对。
Total of four arrests. Four arrests.
总共四次逮捕。四次逮捕。
Yeah, four arrests.
对，四次逮捕。
First time to sit down and have a cup of coffee and relax and unwind. This is my regular hangout here. The Golden-- what is it? Pancake?
第一次坐下来喝杯咖啡，放松放松。这是我经常来的地方。金——那是什么？煎饼？
I don't know. You come here all the time.
不知道。你一直都来这儿。
I know. I come in here all the time. I used to know. 2971 Lincoln. Mike is always hanging around, and then there's, well, Bob over there. He's sitting on the end. Hey, Bob. How you doing? Donna, Mary. Dave, the one cab driver. I've come here quite a bit.
我知道。我一直来这儿。我曾经知道。林肯路2971号。迈克总是在这儿晃悠，还有，好吧，那边的鲍勃。他坐在最后面。嘿，鲍勃。你好吗？唐娜，玛丽。戴夫，那个出租车司机。我来过很多次。
19th and West Belmont. 19th and West Belmont.
第19大街和西贝尔蒙特。第19大街和西贝尔蒙特。
Damon and Belmont.
达蒙和贝尔蒙特。
Right down the street.
就在街那头。
--three men standing on the street. One is a male--
——街上有三个人。一个是男性——
There's a car right now three blocks away, three guys with a gun. Three blocks from here.
现在三条街外有一辆车，三个带枪的家伙。离这儿三条街。
I'm getting description of a male, white, bald head, white t-shirt.
我得到一个描述，男性，白人，光头，白T恤。
Now, supposing they're heading towards Barry, which is this way.
现在，假设他们正朝巴里方向走，就是这边。
They can break our personal if they want. Our lunch break, they're not supposed to. But if it's a hot call-- like, this one might even be bona fide.
他们可以打破我们的私人休息，如果他们愿意的话。我们的午餐休息时间，他们不应该那样。但如果是一个紧急呼叫——像这个甚至可能是真实的。
Probably 8 out of every 10 calls are garbage. They're not-- now there's two calls. Now it might be legitimate.
可能每10个呼叫中有8个是垃圾。它们不是——现在有两个呼叫。现在它可能是合法的。
One thing that happens is, when you get a regular partner-- and even somebody you can work for the first night. You learn their first name, not just their last. And then, where did you work before, are you married? He collects hockey cards. I collect monster memorabilia. Models. I do model collecting. I collect a couple of guitars. I play the guitar. And then you create a bond. You even tell some intimate secrets, you know, things that even the wives don't know about. But you're creating a bond, and people don't realize that. 90% of the job is you and your partner in the car. It can be a long night or it can be a lot of fun.
发生的一件事是，当你有一个固定的搭档——甚至是一个你能共事第一晚的人。你得知他们的名字，不仅仅是姓。然后，你在哪儿工作过，你结婚了吗？他收集冰球卡片。我收集怪物纪念品。模型。我做模型收集。我收集了几把吉他。我弹吉他。然后你就建立了一种联系。你甚至会说出一些私密的秘密，你知道，连妻子都不知道的事情。但你在建立联系，人们没意识到这一点。90%的工作是你和你的搭档在车里。这可能是一个漫长的夜晚，也可能非常有趣。
The other thing is if you don't feel like doing anything, on some nights, you don't have to. You might not get a call. You can chill out, drive around. You know, you can just kind of be off in a haze and it doesn't really matter.
另一件事是如果你不想做任何事，有些晚上，你不必做。你可能没收到呼叫。你可以放松，开车转悠。你知道，你可以就像处于一种朦胧状态，这真的没关系。
It's almost 5 o'clock in the morning, AM. Three more hours.
快凌晨5点了，AM。还有三个小时。
Yeah.
是的。
If we don't get a late arrest. 1922 is back with you.
如果我们没收到什么晚间逮捕呼叫。1922回到你们身边了。
They head toward the door.
他们走向门口。
Donna, Pete, we'll see you guys manana.
唐娜，皮特，明天见，伙计们。
Hasta la bye-bye, says Donna, over by the counter.
再见啦，唐娜在柜台边说。
All right, see you guys all later.
好的，回头见，伙计们。
The damn sun is coming up already.
该死的太阳已经出来了。
The damn sun streaks its damn light through the cursed windows. Donna straightens things up a little, surveys the restaurant. She's the waitress that we first interviewed a full day before, the one who brings in cookies on Christmas for everybody. She eyes the morning regulars at the tables.
该死的太阳透过诅咒的窗户投下它该死的光。唐娜稍微整理了一下，打量着餐厅。她就是我们整整一天前采访的第一位服务员，那个圣诞节给大家带饼干的人。她看着桌边的早晨常客。
Well, it's now 5 o'clock Saturday morning. I got one hour and 45 minutes. And I know it sounds a little corny, but I really do enjoy it. As soon as it starts to get daylight, I start to feel good. The day people come in, the nice smells, nice colognes. [LAUGHS] You know, it's kind of wore off on the night people, but the day people, it's so fresh. It's nice, refreshing. Everybody else is getting sleepy and I'm starting to wake up because I'm a day person that's been working nights for 26 years. [LAUGHS] But I'm handling it all right.
嗯，现在是周六凌晨5点。我还有一小时45分钟。我知道这听起来有点俗气，但我真的很享受它。一旦天开始亮，我就开始感觉很好。白天的人进来，好闻的味道，好闻的香水。[笑声]你知道，这对晚上的人来说有点消退了，但白天的人，它是那么新鲜。很好，令人振奋。其他人开始想睡了，而我开始醒过来，因为我是个上了26年夜班的日班人。[笑声]但我应付得来。
Well, our program was produced this week by Julie Snyder and myself, with Alex Blumberg, Blue Chevigny, and Jonathan Goldstein. Other people who did shifts recording at the Golden Apple include Mary Wiltenburg, Joe Richman, who recorded Danielle and Allison, Wendy Dorr recorded the policeman, Oscar and two drunk women who would not go home with him, Tom and Scott, and the lady who explained earthly time.
嗯，我们的节目本周由朱莉·斯奈德和我自己制作，还有亚历克斯·布隆伯格、布鲁·切维尼和乔纳森·戈尔茨坦。其他在金苹果餐厅进行轮班录音的人包括玛丽·威尔滕堡、乔·里奇曼（他录下了丹妮尔和艾莉森）、温迪·多尔（她录下了警察、奥斯卡和两个不愿和他回家的醉酒女人、汤姆和斯科特，以及那个解释地球时间的女士）。
Nancy Updike's story was produced with a grant from the Corporation for Public Broadcasting as part of HearingVoices.com. Many thanks to Tom and Nick and Pete, the owners of the Golden Apple, and dozens of customers that we interviewed over the course of the day. This show was recorded in July of 2000. The Golden Apple still stands at Lincoln Avenue, where it hits Southport. My recommendation is the feta cheese omelet.
南希·厄普代克的故事是凭着美国公共广播公司的资助，作为HearingVoices.com的一部分制作的。非常感谢金苹果餐厅的老板汤姆、尼克和皮特，以及我们在这一天采访的几十位顾客。这个节目是在2000年7月录制的。金苹果餐厅依然矗立在林肯大道与绍斯波特的交汇处。我的建议是菲达芝士煎饼。
Additional production for today's program by Aviva DeKornfeld, Stowe Nelson, and Matt Tierney. Our website, ThisAmericanLife.org, where you can stream over 600 episodes of our program for absolutely free, see all kinds of videos we've made over the years, the musical we did on stage, favorites lists, staff recommendations. Again, ThisAmericanLife.org. Or get our app, which has all that stuff, and you can download as many episodes as you want.
今天节目的额外制作由阿维瓦·德科恩菲尔德、斯托·尼尔森和马特·蒂尔尼完成。我们的网站ThisAmericanLife.org，在那里你可以免费流媒体收听我们节目超过600集，观看我们多年来制作的各种视频、我们在舞台上做的音乐剧、热门列表、员工推荐。再次说明，ThisAmericanLife.org。或者下载我们的应用程序，它拥有所有那些内容，你可以下载尽可能多的节目。
This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia, who's always reminding me--
《美国生活》由PRX公共广播交易所传送到公共广播电台。像往常一样感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚先生，他总是提醒我——
I'm a journalism major, by the way. Yeah. So I understand what you're doing right now.
顺便说一下，我是新闻专业学生。对。所以我理解你现在在做什么。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周回来带来更多《美国生活》的故事。